[Música]
olá a todos boa tarde eu eu sempre
gostei de ouvir as histórias das pessoas
é eu achava que cada uma tinha
particularidades e diferenças e era tão
especial que dava assim unindo os livros
e por causa disso eu cresci querendo ser
contadora de histórias e foi por isso
também que eu escolhi a literatura eu eu
tenho paixão por escrever mas eu tenho
mais paixão ainda por ajudar novos
autores a lançarem as suas ideias e
porém por muito tempo eu jamais imaginei
que eu pudesse estar aqui contando a
minha história
bom quando eu tinha 10 anos
a minha mãe é juntou todas as coisas
importantes que ela tinha em casa chamou
a minha irmã e disse eu já fiz tudo o
que eu tinha para fazer por vocês
eu já cumpri o meu papel de mãe e eu vou
embora vou mudar a minha vida e nós é
claro ficamos com aquela grande
interrogação na testa é o que foi que eu
fiz de errado
a imagem mais dívida que eu tenho desse
tempo é da minha irmãzinha ela tinha
sete anos ela era muito mirradinha ela
agarrada nas pernas da minha mãe é
porque na cabecinha dela achava que essa
era técnica infalível para evitar que a
mãe pudesse caminhar e se minha mãe não
podia caminhar
ela não podia ir embora o que é evidente
não deu certo a minha mãe foi embora
nessa época eu já era uma adolescente
uma pré-adolescente muito complicada mas
dos 10 anos aos 14 anos eu me tornei
verdadeiramente difícil eu passei a
odiar todo mundo ao meu redor todo mundo
literalmente eu não gostava das pessoas
com quem eu convivi ano com no eu tinha
raiva de tudo e essa raiva
toda e me fez conhecer novos amigos
pessoas que estavam mais eram mais
parecidas comigo e eles foram me
mostrando que o mundo podia ser legal e
que tudo podia ficar melhor a dor a dor
sumir ao sofrimento sumia depois de uma
pequena dose e assim eu comecei de
pequenas em pequenas doses com coisas
lícitas e depois eu fui para
literalmente tudo o que aparecia na
minha frente eu não tinha reservas
é evidente que isso me trouxe assim
grandes problemas problemas na escola
problemas sociais diversos e meu pai
ficou preocupado com isso e ele resolveu
então que estava na hora de mudar a mim
e à minha irmã na casa dos nossos avós
onde ele achava que nós vamos ter mais
suporte
porém para mim as coisas continuaram
piorando
eu continuei tendo muitos problemas na
escola muitos problemas sociais comecei
a ter problemas com as autoridades com a
polícia como alcoólico veio de pressão
tentativa de suicídio eu gostava de me
cortar e de me queimar
eu me tornei assim uma pessoa muito
eficiente em autodestruição
nessa época inclusive eu conheci um
traficante que disse que podia se casar
comigo para me tirar de casa seria uma
grande mudança
meu pai é evidente achou que as coisas
estavam ficando muito complicadas de
novo e nova mudança para nós
e dessa vez ele escolheu que nós
deveríamos ele nos mandou morar num
monastério onde nós poderíamos oferecer
tratamento principalmente para mim
poderia oferecer tratamento e aquilo
para mim pareceu terrível é vida
meditativo a vida interior
eu gostava de rock roupa que rock eu não
ia sentar para meditar de jeito nenhum
mas a vida ali dentro era bem diferente
do que eu imaginava é além dos estudos é
claro que as crianças adolescentes
tinham que ter
eu nós começamos a receber diversos
tipos de de tarefas guardava antes de
amanhecer para tratar os animais que
eram de
uma ação e viviam soltos no lugar eu fiz
diversos trabalhos manuais e à medida
que fui crescendo também é comecei a
trabalhar na pequena gráfica que existia
lá então nós montávamos livros e depois
também foi trabalhar na biblioteca
várias catalogação vários tipos de
tarefas dentro da biblioteca e foi ali
que eu aprendi tudo sobre livros e sobre
publicação de livros então finalmente
parecia que as coisas estavam andando
andando um pouquinho melhor e pelas
tantas idas e vindas desse nosso mundo
as chamadas desse instituto diz da vida
humana é preciso ser fechado
daí eu me vi ali uma jovem adulta uma
adulta que precisava encarar todas as
responsabilidades da vida adulta que
todos nós sabemos o que é
tem que trabalhar ganhar seu pão tem que
perseguir os modelos de sucesso que
existem têm que ter uma casa um carro e
assim vai
então eu tive vários é tive alguns
relacionamentos bem complicados que
foram muito difíceis de deixar bem
abusivos e eu tentei alguns negócios com
a minha irmã eu falei e nessa busca de
sucesso idealizado eu cheguei a um ponto
que eu não sabia mais o que fazer tudo
estava dando errado novamente parecia
que eu não conseguia me engrenar eu não
conseguia me encontrar
voltou à depressão voltou pensamento
suicida e assim foi
aí isso é aquele momento da vida que eu
acho que muitos já tiveram que se chama
ponto de ruptura ou você empreende uma
grande mudança para sair daquilo ou você
se acomoda e se afunda mais o que eu
quero ilustrar com a minha história que
existem duas formas de nós nos
relacionamos com as mudanças uma delas é
nós temos passivos
a outra é nós temos ativos eu acredito
que todos nós já ouvimos aquela frase
seja protagonista da sua própria
história
nós somos é passivos as mudanças quando
nós vivemos em modo passivo
nós não somos protagonistas nós somos
personagens menores da nossa história
nós não empreendemos nada nós até
achamos que estamos agindo mas na
verdade não só estamos respondendo
emocionalmente para as coisas que nos
acontecem
e essa história também quero mostrar
outra coisa que a ideia geral da
humanidade que existe de estabilidade e
segurança é ilusória porque se muitas
coisas acontecem conosco é vindas das
nossas próprias mãos vindas das mãos de
terceiros
ouvindo pelas próprias circunstâncias do
mundo coisas que nós simplesmente não
podemos controlar
então se todas essas coisas acontecem
conosco e nós não podemos prever
não existe segurança e se não existe
segurança não existe nenhuma garantia de
estabilidade porque nós temos que
empreender um trabalho saindo da
passividade para a atividade
aí nós pensamos o que então eu vou me
vou me mover eu vou ser um agente eu vou
ser ativo
aí nós nos deparamos com o medo das
próprias incertezas que nós encaramos
que existe nos e também nós encaramos um
outro problema que é não gostar da
mudança porque aceitar as coisas como
elas já estão é muito mais confortável
nós conseguimos viver muito melhor com a
ideia de passado ou com aquela idéia de
segurança de que tudo é como sempre foi
e deve ser o sim o passado foi bom
a pessoa pode se acomodar tranquilamente
naquela aquela e dinâmica vida do
passado o único problema é que quem vive
no passado nunca constrói nada para o
futuro ele nunca vai para frente ele
nunca evolui e todos nós sabemos que
todas as grandes coisas deste mundo
foram construídas pelas mãos de pessoas
desacomodar dadas e não por pessoas
acomodadas a humanidade já
a histeria evoluído jamais teria
alcançado grau que alcançou ela errou
errou mas jamais teria se movido jamais
teria mudado se todos nós estivéssemos
contentes com as coisas do jeito que
elas são e nós nunca tivéssemos
empreendido mudanças
então isso vem da nossa característica
essencial de ser humano de sermos
sonhadores
nós sonhamos com o futuro sonhamos com o
lá o problema da passividade quando nós
sonhamos é que o nosso sonho está sempre
lá longe longe longe e inalcançável e
nós não vamos em direção a ele
daí as pessoas vêm nos dão aquela aquele
concelho a tudo que você precisa na sua
vida é criar uma meta cria uma meta
coloque ela no seu alvo e persiga não
olha nem por usuários nem para trás e ok
isso é ótimo se você sabe exatamente
onde você está exatamente onde você quer
ir mas vamos combinar que nós nem sempre
sabemos aonde quer ir queremos ir
e nós nem sempre sabemos onde nós
estamos
então daí isso nos limita nós ficamos
ali parados olhando para longe
talvez o que nós pudéssemos fazer então
o invés de pensar em uma meta é pensar
no horizonte usar a metáfora do
horizonte
ele é enorme está longe muito distante e
nós estamos sempre focando nele sempre
olhando para ele é evidente que para nós
irmos em direção a ele
nós precisamos fazer alguma coisa isso
quer dizer nós temos que nos mexer e
quando nós começamos a nos mexer nós
começamos a aceitar muitas coisas novas
nós conhecemos pessoas novas uma que
outra ali
nós vamos conhecendo características
novas das coisas nós vamos aumentando a
nossa perspectiva nossa percepção acerca
do mundo
nós vamos aprendendo muito acerca do
mundo e acerca de nós mesmos
e quando nós fazemos isso nós evoluímos
junto com a própria mudança nós mudamos
com a própria mudança daí vem aquela
questão que é porque queremos mudança
por
e devemos querer lá porque a mudança é
sempre um desafio sempre é um desafio e
todo o desafio nos desacomodar nos move
nos coloca alerta nos faz nos mexer e
quando nós fazemos isso nós aprendemos
nós melhoramos nós evoluímos e quando
nós evoluímos o mundo todo evolui
conosco
obrigado
[Aplausos]